You're going to see a lot of new topics
and new ideas in this nanodegree.
Because you're going to see so
many, it means
we're just not going to be able to focus
on acquiring fluency because, remember,
fluency generally takes a really long
time to acquire in even one thing.
So, instead, the goal's going to
be to get to ability In the most
important topics that are fundamental
throughout programming.
In addition, you're going to
gain awareness of many topics,
and through this combination of
awareness and ability, you're
going to have the skills to do amazing
things, as well as the understanding
of what you need to do next depending
on your own personal goals.
Maybe you want to make a webpage.
Maybe you want to get a job
as a front end developer.
Right now you probably wouldn't
even know where to begin.
But, at the end of this nano degree
you'll have enough ability and
awareness to make informed decisions.
But along the way,
you will experience frustration.
Frustration happens whenever you do
something in which you're not fluent,
and in computer programming,
it happens even if you are fluent.
What this means is at some point during
this journey, you're probably going to
have some thoughts, thoughts like,
why can't I get this?
Or why won't this work?
Or why is this so hard for me?
I know I had all of these thoughts,
and everyone goes through them.
But it's not frustration that's the real
problem, frustration is inevitable.
The problem happens when this
frustration turns into something worse.